SPEAKER: When we
first met Sal Khan
18 months ago he was working
at home in a converted closet
in the heart of Silicon Valley.
The former hedge fund
analyst had recently
quit his job to do
something that, at the time,
sounded a bit strange.
SAL KHAN: Right now
I'm cash flow negative.
SPEAKER: He gave up a
paycheck with a hefty ambition
to help educate
the world online.
SAL KHAN: A lot people
thought I as kind of crazy.
Obviously, when every
waking hour you have
you would sneak into a
room and make math videos
and put them on YouTube, people
kind of question, what's up?
SPEAKER: What originally
started as some math tutoring
for a cousin turned into
a global phenomenon.
The idea didn't seem
so crazy anymore.
Though Khan, a brilliant
MIT and Harvard
grad with a wife and
two children to support,
was slowly starting to
run out of his savings.
That's when he learned that
one comment from the right man
can change everything-- an
out of the blue endorsement
from Bill Gates.
BILL GATES: There's a new
website that I've just been
using with my kids recently
called Khan Academy, K-H-A-N,
just one guy doing some
unbelievable 15-minute
tutorials.
SAL KHAN: It was surreal.
I mean, it's one of those things
where it's this person that you
grew up knowing,
almost a hero most
of your life, all of your life.
SPEAKER: Soon Gates kicked in
a million and a half dollars.
He also won $2
million from Google.
It had a contest to
see who had the best
ideas to better the planet.
SAL KHAN: We did
now have millions
of dollars to essentially
pursue the dream.
SPEAKER: A dream
that's enabled him
to post more than 2,300 videos
on a host of different subjects
from math, to
history, to economics.
SAL KHAN: It involves an
expansion of the central bank's
balance sheet.
SPEAKER: Khan has
expanded his approach
to create a software
platform for classrooms.
And he's working closely with
one local school district.
TEACHER: Why don't you start
with reviewing some of these
and getting them out of the way?
SAL KHAN: It was literally,
it started with me just
saying, look, my
cousins have a problem.
I think I have a solution
for my cousin's problem.
So I did it.
And it required pretty
much no resources,
a little bit of my time.
It was like, oh wait.
My cousins liked it.
And other people liked it.
Let's keep going.
SPEAKER: With his newfound
fame and resources--
SAL KHAN: This is the
worldwide headquarters
of the Khan Academy.
SPEAKER: --Khan has been
able to ditch the bedroom
closet for an office.
And he now has a small
staff to take things
to an even higher level.